اول جرائم الطعن كانت في هذا الشارع
لطالبين جامعيين في التاسعه عشره من العمر
اثناء عودتهما الى سكنهما الطلابي بعد
احتفالهما بنهايه الفصل الدراسي
الطالبان هما برنامج
لفظ انفاسهما وسط صرخات مؤلمه ايقظت ساكنه
هذا الشارع عائله بارنبي وبر وصفت دمرها
الكامل في خط في حياه ابنها الشاب الجميل
واللامع في بدايه مرحله البلوغ والذي كان
يتطلع الى كل شيء في الحياه نادي هوكي
كانت جرايس كومار تنتمي اليه عبر عن حزنه
الشديد لسماع خبر مقتل جريس الموهوبه
والمتفانيه المعروفه بالمرح والود
حفل تابيني احتضنته هذه الكنيسه وسط نوتين
غالبيه من حضروا هذا التجمع التابينيه
طلاب جامعيون يعرفون عن قرب او عن بعد
الضحيتين او مجرد التعبير عن التضامن
والوقوف ضد كل من يهدد سلامه سكان هذه
المدينه
اكثر من 400 شخص اضاءوا الشموع ووضعوا
باقات من الورود للتعبير عن مواساتهم لاسر
الضحايا
نحن لا نفهم ما حدث والناس ارادوا ان
يجتمعوا لتقديم التعازي والمواساه والصلاه
لما اصابنا من حزن مشترك حقيقي في هذه
الحادثه الضحيه الثالثه هو في الستينيات
من العمر تعتقد الشظط ان المشتبه به
الوحيده بارتكاب عمليه الطعن والمعتقله
لديها استخدم مركبه الضحيه لدحس ثلاثه
اشخاص احدهم في حاله حرجه بينما اصابه
اخرين كانت خفيفه
غالبيه الشوارع اعيد فتحها لحركه السير
بينما التحقيقات مستمره لمعرفه ظروف
ارتكاب ثلاث حوادث امنيه خطيره في المدينه
من مصطفى زارو العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات